tonight's Gordon H Smith
is William F Baker I would like to
acknowledge the generosity of Gordon
Smith the distinguished engineer
specializing in building enclosure
systems who has endowed this series mr.
Smith a graduate of Yale and a great
friend both to the college and to this
school was the lead consultant on the
window wall design for Rudolph and
Moorea halls few years ago and for the
restoration of the Conn building of the
University art gallery among his many
distinguished projects as this is custom
mr. Smith is with us in the audience
tonight and it's my pleasure to welcome
him in establishing this series this
lecture series Gordon Smith's intention
was to bring to our school speakers
whose work reflected an enlightened
pragmatism that his work which combines
the highest level of technological
accomplishment with enlightened with the
artistic excellence most of the speakers
in this series have been drawn from the
engineering professions such as York's
Lake Roberts Illman sessile Bauman les
Robertson Chris wise Werner sobic and
Anja Brazil but there have also been
architects such as Myron Goldsmith and
Rafael viñoly and occasionally
historians of technology such as David
Billington last year's Smith lecturer
was Hanif Kara the london-based
structural engineer tonight for the 24th
Smith lecture we welcome William Baker
structural engineering partner for
Skidmore Owings and Merrill throughout
his distinguished career mr. Baker has
dedicated himself to structural
innovation his best-known contribution
has been the development of the
buttressed core structural system for
the Burj Khalifa the world's tallest
man-made structure while widely regarded
for his work on super tall buildings his
expertise also extends to a broad survey
of structures like the Millennium park's
Jay Pritzker pavilion and the BP
pedestrian bridge both
Chicago mr. banker is also known for his
work on long span roof structures such
as the Korean Airlines Operations hangar
in Seoul South Korea and the Virginia
Beach Convention Center as well as for
and he's less well-known for this but as
well as for his amazing collaborations
with artists like Jamie carpenter and
his work on small-scale project with Tom
Pfeiffer and even the occasional house
as with Jeannie gang who is with us here
tonight this evening for this lecture
mr. Baker is a graduate in civil
engineering at the University of
Missouri at Columbia and of the
University of Illinois at
urbana-champaign highly respected by his
peers he has been showered with honors
in the United States as well as abroad
when we discussed what the topic of his
talk might be mr. Baker proposed 3-1
tackling the ethical dilemmas posed by
tall and super tall buildings a second
discussing the issue of scale in
relationship to tall buildings and a
third and analysis of the Burj Kalifa
and the close collaboration between the
architects and engineers that led to its
final design I asked mr. Baker to tackle
this last subject in the expectation
that his talk would embrace the other
two topics and that if it did not they
would be addressed in what I hope will
be a lively question-and-answer session
that will follow please join me in
welcoming bill Baker the 24th Gordon H
Smith lecture as he delivers the lecture
Burj Khalifa a new paradigm
okay I'm very pleased to be here and I'd
like to thank mr. Smith for funding this
series my New York partners have the
opportunity to work with him quite a bit
on such as the reglazing of the lever
house and Time Warner and various
projects so there's a long long
relationship between my firm and it is
now I'm going to talk about this this
very very tall thing that you see in the
slide okay and why do we do these things
you know white why is that even there
you know what's this desire to go higher
you know it's it's it's very an age and
we always want to go to over the top of
the mountain you know why are these
people going on top of the mountain
there's there's no good practical reason
and certainly part of our mythology or
history or our cultural history is you
know the desire to go higher and the
problems of going higher okay you know
this this didn't do well for mankind and
you know not only we're trying to go
higher we're trying to just hang out
over the abyss this is a Yale graduates
project Ross Weimer that we did on the
Sears Tower where we actually put glass
boxes hanging off the side of the Telus
billion in the North America so just you
know there's this ever extending desire
to get out and experience height as part
of it okay
but the reason we were able to do this
is because of Technology now when you
think about it for the whole history of
mankind thousands of years of
civilization you lived close to the
ground where you could walk up you know
you know I know that the tenement saw
and you know the Lower East Side I don't
know how many stories they were but you
know that was about the limit as high as
you could go then came two things one is
the in 1885 steel frame here you see
exposed underneath the brick and the
elevator structure and vertical
transportation these are these are the
technological things that made it happen
so here we are 1885 which really isn't
that long ago so here's here's where the
state of the life was in 1885 and
roughly 100 years ago the metlife
building was the world's tallest
building okay and so you know and that
that time frame is relatively sure we're
talking about
for years they you know are going from
this to that and not that many more
years until the Empire State and here's
where we are it's certainly you know a
very very dramatic change and and I want
to talk a bit about how we got there and
at the time that the birds topped out
that these were the 10 tallest buildings
the world and and I wanted to point out
that they're dominated by Chicago and
New Haven ok there I think there are
five of these are our Sol buildings from
Chicago and then there's two or three
here they're from New Haven with mr.
Pelley so who's also a University of
Illinois graduate by the way I want to
point out okay the and so you can see
it's quite a bit different because as
you see you know there was this rapid
rise and technology from the from the
home insurance building until you got to
the Empire State Building we've done of
course economic and war and the like out
of the way and then it kind of went up a
little bit kind of sorta okay and and
the growth was very very minor and they
came down to Wars about how do you
measure tall buildings and and all this
kind of unnecessary politics
and so so here we are 2010 when it
opened with the Burj Khalifa which is a
roughly a little over half mile tall
it's uh it's 828 meters whereas half
miles 805 now when I talk about this
building I want you to think about three
issues okay and it's just kind of framed
the discussion first of all when you see
a giant skyscraper do not think of it as
anything but one giant beam coming out
of the ground okay
if you think of it as thousands of beams
and columns it's conceptually too
difficult we can't deal with that our
brains aren't that big so if you think
about it and you think of it
conceptually as one you know that's a
giant beam with a lot of holes in it
it's kind of heavily perforated tube
coming out of the ground but but I
pulled this out of the som archives is
what foz Khan and how langar did here's
the evolution of the building and they
actually they approximated the the
moment inertia as if it were a single
beam coming on the ground primordial
Ridge and if you look at the bottom of
the building you know Faust con named it
a bundle too but it's really simply a a
giant being with four webs okay and
essentially four flanges and and and
when the wind blows and acts like a beam
you have the de stress distribution it's
not quite linear because of the
penetration but but it's it's that
conceptual breakthrough that they that
they did it's kind of interesting we
were the school of architecture the the
modern terra bullying was a lot of times
when I say was invented in the basement
of a one-story building which is crown
Hall and IIT you know Myron goldsmith
and father Kahn did a series of studies
that kind of led to this technology I
also want you to think about issues of
scale I'd mention that earlier I'm not
going to talk too much about it but let
me just
well if I were twice as tall I'd be
twice as wide
I'd be twice as thick and I'd weigh
eight times as much there's a real scale
problem there okay and and so think
about that I'll you can as I showed the
buildings think about that we'll talk
about them also I'd also like to think
about issues of appropriateness okay you
know one should be somewhat circumspect
when someone does something that's so
extreme okay obviously this is a fairly
extreme structure and one of the things
I really bothers me quite a bit now have
engineers become facilitators of dreams
but too often I think they're the
enablers willful excess okay if you go
back if you go back to say 30 years
buildings and architecture had to be
fairly rational because that's all the
engineer could calculate it had to be
very organized and so there was this
discipline put on the on the tech on the
architecture by the limited
computational skills of the engineer and
nowadays we're doing stuff like this
okay
and and so you know now having said that
there's some extreme structures from the
past which the world would be very sad
if it didn't have okay you might say
that this is a very expensive restaurant
okay but you know the certainly the
world be lesser so it's you know there
should be this dialogue about should be
a critical dialogue like when is that we
should do these things and when is it we
should not do these things because
because the restriction that used to be
put on from the outside is no longer
there and I think this is something that
we should talk about and so I would
suggest that you'll think about this you
know I don't know I mean I've done I've
enabled wilful excess or inspired reins
but it's something we should we should
at least talk about now one of the
things that that comes into my
engineering is personal values and
design and it just came to me I was
working on Roden crater with James
Turrell okay and he and so we were doing
this fumarole which is a it's a lunar
observatory on the side of the mountain
you can you can see it like right there
it was supposed to catch your moon rises
and moon sets for two thousand years
it's kind of like it was a basically a
giant eyeball 40 foot diameter sphere
inside the side of the side of the
volcano and and it's not a cylinder and
an som got involved from the engineering
and the technical architecture side to
help him realize this thing okay and so
he and I were one time making a
presentation to a potential donor and
and what we had done is we had given it
order and hierarchy and issues like this
and I described to the owner that what
have we done and he brought me see and
simplicity okay because I'm from Chicago
alright that's that's that's my
preference and he said no no Quaker
simplicity because James was raised a
Quaker and I did not know what that
meant
I'm from a small town in Missouri you
know or it's it's all Calvinist and you
know so yeah it's the so I started going
to Quaker services just to find out what
James meant okay and and and just as I
was Midwestern simple overview if you
believe in simplicity in dress speech
food and James said his mother always
told him to step into the light alright
and so and you look at his art is it
speaks of those values
values that were not necessarily may be
rooted in aesthetics but became as
aesthetic okay simplicity and the light
and we've had the opportunity we're
working on another project with him
right now this is the rice University
observation that's under construction
and he does these things this looks like
paint paint thin roof floating and
floating in the Houston sky and so so
I'm going to propose these are the
things that I try to do in my work and I
won't I'm not saying they're virtues
that maybe they're a curse but they're
part they're part of things I picked up
maybe before my professional career that
come through I'm a great believer in a
utility that you should bill it makes
something that's actually of use a great
believer and this is very common in
engineers efficiency this is a General
Motors headquarters I did with a Adrian
Smith it's it's tensegrities structure
you know it's like you can't take
anything away and all the load paths are
complete and balancing economy this is
another building I did with Bruce Graham
which is you know actually a very very
efficient building that actually spans
over a rail yard which is why it's both
a building and a bridge I believe in in
simplicity okay I love this little
banner yeah at the end of my career I
want to have five slides okay I think a
good career is five good projects okay
and and and I'm not sure what those five
are yet but I'm working on it this might
be one of this is our little band shell
I did a judge Jamie carpenter it's on an
island the Mississippi it up at st. Paul
Minnesota just very very simple I
believe in clarity okay this is a this
is the thing Jeanie I are working on
right now there's a little house in on a
tiny lot in Manhattan Beach California
it's certainly you know the living space
is up very clearly in the box above
supportive of and this is unbelievably
high seismic area we're trying to do
this oh and and the in the Box there
we're using a new product we have a
span-to-depth ratio of one to 70 on the
floor we use these as this new thing
called SPS panels minimalism you know I
just
love the Farnsworth house one of my
mentors main mentors was Marvin
Goldsmith who was that both the
architect and engineer on the Farnsworth
House Fermi's and in you know just just
you know the reductive process at all
elegance I wish I designed this thing
someday in my life I wish I could design
something as utilitarian and beautiful
and elegant is this thing yeah you see
this across the prairies that you know
in Illinois and Indiana these irrigation
things you know it's like you cannot
take anything away from there I don't
know about the wheels but you know
though it's certainly the the there's
the structure and the function is all
integrated harmony you know this is a
tower I did with Jamie carpenter out of
Nebraska and then proportion this
actually near here this is on fishers
island this was Tom Pfeifer so it's a
little house we're actually the UH the
mullions are the columns Gordon okay so
but by the time but timely we made the
mullions big enough to take the window
we could hold the roof for free and then
appropriateness okay this is certainly
the inappropriate one slide I hate I
truly hate to see a plot structure
applied as decoration okay this person
wanted a colonnade they wanted Terra
okay you know and then so they stuck
these ridiculous columns here and then
and then the garage what happened okay
rational this is something I'm doing
with Ross Weimer right now in Sydney
Australia you know where there's a logic
and we were actually doing we do a great
deal of research and structural topology
and and without going to detail this
this bracing on the side has about four
innovations which you've never been done
before
okay order and hierarchy you know not
everything is equally important you know
you've got it you've got it you've got
to set up your your building or your
your thoughts in a way that you know
when things class because designing
building it's all about resolving
clashes your first design for a building
is unbelievably messy because you solve
a thousand different problems one at a
time and then you pull them together and
you pull them together and and I think
Mark Twain once wrote a letter to his
friend and said might my letter have
been much shorter if I had more time you
know to actually edit your work down and
reduce it and reduce it and it reduce it
and and my goal which I don't always
achieve is an ample snatch ative if I
can describe what I'm doing with a noun
plus an adjective
maybe I have an idea what I'm doing and
maybe I can explain it to my team what
we're doing maybe I can resolve issues
of hierarchy and what does this mean and
actually I guess I know fuzz can do this
intuitively our purpose the the the
first frame building is the chestnut the
wit tower with Myron Goldsmith it's
called a framed tube an amplifier ship
the the bunch Brunswick building is tube
in tube though it's kind of two nouns
then you have the Sears Tower as a
bundle tube that john hancock is a brace
tube and so so there was always this
this noun plus the modifier and the
building I'm going to show you today is
a buttress core and this was a
deliberate part of the design process
what did we create it let's give it a
name let's make our thoughts were clear
so let me start to tell it to you a bit
about the story of the Burj Khalifa now
yeah it's big okay
it's 828 meters there's a big dark
secret while we're doing the design
because there's this great competition
who's going to do the world's tallest
building and we had lots of subject fuse
going on
and and the like and eventually this is
where we ended up but this is where we
started on March 1st 2003 adrian smith
gorgeous Thea and I went to New York
City to see some guys in the Middle East
who are in town interviewing the usual
suspects I'm sure they probably came up
here and and so we had just finished a
project in Korea and while we're
designing this called Tara palace tree
and while we were working on that I I
can't it came to conclusion with some
changes this building this structural
system could go quite high it's not the
system we had in the Burj but it was
like a predecessor but this is the
building that we had at the very
beginning the brief was has the world's
tallest building so this was 10 meters
taller than the world's tallest building
so it met the brief and we actually
talked a bit about this this building
behaved very badly very very badly and
I'll talk a little bit later and I do
think if it hadn't behaved so badly we
wouldn't have gotten so tall at the end
because we had some real problems to
solve and so it was that height in the
spring of 2003 and then in the summer it
jumped up around 7 or 25 meters and then
it stayed there to 2005 we were already
in construction and then in December
2005 at Groot
8:28 it grew 300 meters during the
design process a thousand feet ok and
and so that that was a bit of a
challenge ok so it's it is a new
paradigm because it is different now if
you ears give an idea how big it is a
little referential you know photographs
if it were downtown Chicago
you know don't tell David child's okay
we we took his site or you go to Midtown
so idea of the scale or you know put it
put it next to the NatWest in London I
get an idea there's the Gherkin off to
the side of course those are you
familiar with London no it doesn't no
way does it belong in the city it should
be out of Canary Wharf
you know it's certainly it's much better
but it's better at Canary Wharf but
gives you an idea of the scale of this
thing now here it is in its actual
location this is a form of those kind of
bizarre offshore islands are making okay
and this is why I was still under
construction but you get it get an idea
how it is on the skyline now as far as
area P it's big 3 million square feet
that's a big building but it's not that
big the the the John Hancock's 2.5
million square feet Sears tower's 4.4
million square feet is this actually has
less area than Sears Tower and that's a
very important point on the issue of
scale the base you know because it's
Dubai that's parking it has another
couple million down there so about a
five million total square footage now
I'm going to describe the building to
you so you know it is and then I'll talk
about how we got there and at the very
bottom we have these massive half
million square foot floor plates which
are you know mechanical spaces parking
ballrooms stuff like that and above
there is the armani hotel just the first
armani hotel and that was a bit of a
painful process you think a guy who came
comes out with a new fashion every
season would like make decisions fast
well this is his first you know hotel so
it took a little while so these are
their money hotel then above here is
well here's what the floor plate looks
like
so why shake the building's
fundamentally residential now now one of
the paradigm changes is if you went into
the into the World Trade Center the one
that collapsed you had a column every 40
inches and the glass was only 20 inches
wide it was very very old pick 50%
opaque and if you got back from the
window you couldn't see out okay now if
you go to the Amoco building which is
now called the BP building I guess keep
changing the name and once again it's
50% opaque you have five foot of glass
and five foot of structure a serious
Tower cuz it did the bundle too with
those interior frame lines they able to
go to 10-foot of glass and five foot of
structure so it's it's it's two-thirds
go open this this you have a normal
building you have 30 foot of glass and
then a two foot column so so so even
though you're under that this is
tremendously tall building and also on
the sir
tarah the distance from the from the
core to the outside window is 75 feet
this is 30 feet you know it's it's
typical residential construction okay
above there we have out these service
residential kind of and then above there
more residential than the floor plates
set sips it's back my companies you know
architects and engineers planners and
likely firms often called som which
really some people think stands for
Skidmore Owings and Merrill it actually
means stay on module okay there there's
a rigorous nine meter module 30 foot
modules I took to the to the structure
and so as a setback you know we hit we
have these rules to being the thing
because you got to got to get under
control one is no transfers okay
everything's got a lineup it's so you
can you have a and you stay our module
and you know and so that was we were
like some shouting matches so we had to
get people back into the religion at
certain points above there is the luxury
residential this takes you up to 108
okay now if you take the blue the brown
and the yellow those are the residential
floors and they those were all sold in
2004 in two nights
okay now the they're the client was a
little didn't hit the peak of the market
so he's you know he felt left money on
the table like at this point I think he
got he sold it because everyone had to
put if you bought a unit she had to put
50% down in six months and so they got a
lot of money at the same time we were
doing this we were doing Donald Trump's
building the Chicago the 92 story of
Trump Tower and once again that was kind
of mininum it's all this cash flow you
know like you know we actually opened
the hotel while we're still pumping
concrete on the Trump Tower in Chicago
and that was so he could close on the
like it closed there because there was
some service apartment area he wanted to
be able to get occupancy and close on
the units to get his money now and so
the floor plate sets back and then we
get into the corporate Suites now
originally these pink floors were
supposed to be palaces in the sky and
the client said okay let's can make them
office space we're going like this is
terrible office space okay these are
lousy you know these are they're nice a
nice big apartments but there
you know you know mean little spaces
said no no you got to understand what do
Baez Dubai is like this neutral land
where everybody can go to do business
they don't have the social restrictions
if you're a Saudi and you're Saudi
businessman you have an office in Dubai
because that's where everybody can go to
meet you because no one can getting a
visa to Saudi is awful and it's not a
pleasant place to go once you get there
you know but but here you know so so so
everybody who's anybody in Pakistan
India you know Iraq Iran you know all
the Arab countries they all have offices
in Dubai to do business and so that's
what these were and so these were things
that were sold over tea you know one
floor at a time or part of the Florida
time and the floor plate sets back and
then of course you have to have the
mechanical spaces that are in between
the lungs of the building mechanically
it's like a series of 30 storey
buildings stacked on each other vertical
transportation very very critical now
one of the things about the both Trump
and this building is their residential
which means you have a lot fewer
elevators okay and that's a big deal and
what's interesting about the Burj we
have 34 elevators and 19 shafts okay so
we did that by recycling the space
because it because I knew too I needed
to tie the building together for gravity
reasons at the very beginning early
building immediate I said - I said I
need and these are residential floors so
the floor floor was small I said I need
three modules for my mechanical floors
to tie the building together and then
there when the technical are consistent
great now I can stack my pits above my
elevator machine rooms and so so so that
was what was done in order to keep
recycling the elevators and so this is
how the building elevators if you're if
you're up if you're down below level 39
you service from the ground like
normally but above there you do a sky
lobby you go you go up the sky lobby and
you transfer and so then elevator shafts
drop out
76 another sky lobby that you you you
shuttle to and then get on the local
bank now on the on the office this
change happens so late we couldn't do it
conventionally it's actually usually
more efficient to have your your sky
lobby in the middle of the zone right at
the bottom
so that you can feed up and down it's
actually faster and so so we actually
put our sky lobby and partial the way up
into the into the Pink's of the office
zone and then finally we have the the
freight elevators the service lifts and
when we ran out of cable they are two
longest elevators 500 meters because
that's all they can do okay at least at
least at the time now they're looking
for your tour and you actually had to
have a transfer on them on the on the
service lift yeah and then those service
lists are also used for evacuation that
there's a as well so some of the other
elevators there's three stairs since you
guys are all architects they're all
concrete in case three stairs
so you know very much a hardened thing
and then we have a refuge floor it's
kind of like to do in Asia a lot because
of the dead end quarter a condition that
the stairs would move back and that we
take that as an opportunity carried
refuge areas for people to rest if they
had to go down now I've walked down the
building I was I didn't I've never
walked up anyway yeah and I was in for
cracks in the concrete like engineers do
and so I had a little map of although
highly most highly loaded link beams and
I was able to check out all these link
beams and walk only down about 45
minutes so it's not too bad
and then for Gordon the facade is is
it's a stainless steel and somewhat
reflective glass aloha Chloe we have we
have these mullions that come out one of
the things we like to do is we like our
buildings to be rough
it creates service turbulence it's like
people say the skin of our barracuda
their skin of skin of a shark is rough
and has to do it reducing the drag next
time you're in a big airplane you'll see
there's a series of blades on the upper
surface of the wing those are to create
a little board of C's to help decrease
the drag on the plane so this is one
things what we like to do structurally
is have roughness on the outside surface
of the building and these are unitized
systems they're they're installed you
know the guys you know double tied back
so if you happens to go over it doesn't
go too far the of course you have to
wash the windows on these things okay
and so at each of these bands these
mechanical floors are these bands that
there's like garages
where you you you you you store these
essentially cranes that are used to
maintain the building and and this is
and some of these rods are decorative
but two of the rods are actually the
rails that the crane goes around the
building okay so that's description of
what it is it's a residential building
it's the middle east let me talk about
what made it possible okay the and a lot
of things luck had a big part of it
having a cop getting the right client
having a good interview in New York in
2003 being in a place that was all about
optimism with a client who is all about
optimism you know people who create
skyscrapers are optimistic could you
imagine what New York was like in the
20s oh man you know it was like you know
go get it you know it was it was like
this you know it wasn't people you know
you know trying to hold it back every
I'm sure everyone was rushing forward uh
you know in Chicago still a little bit
that way except we wanted the economy to
support it we were trying to do this
building called seven South Dearborn
which is gonna be a 2,000 foot Tower in
Chicago and we went to the City Council
to present it out of the planning bureau
there was one person for the public
there and they were there in support of
the tower so it was like you know K kind
of a different different experience okay
so what are the technical things well a
structural system I'll talk about that
when engineering which is a big deal
integration of systems and then the
construction technology okay it's a
concrete building okay if tall buildings
were to end in the mid 80s you would say
that they are number one structural
steel number two they're in North
America and with the exception of the
Hancock their office this is none of the
above there's been a complete change
okay it's certainly not in the US and
it's not office it's residential and
quite frankly it's easy to do a super
tall building and residential than
office just the economy works works
easier you know you know I have the
whole thing about fewer elevators and
the like and then then that concrete is
cut you know he used to be steel was the
industrialized material the kind of
concrete is now somewhat and when you
get to really tall buildings
if you have to pick everything up by
crane you have problem with the wind and
the taller you are the less more
downtime you have so the most the less
pick time you have the better and I'll
talk a bit about that and here what we
had but we had very very ordinary things
and I was very I gave a lecture in Korea
once and they I was criticized roundly
by the audience by not doing something
more inventive well I was really proud I
did something very ordinary okay because
I wanted to have people actually bid on
the job all right you know so we had
walls slabs a flat plate slabs walls and
a couple of columns that's it just the
way they're arranged and and we we spent
a lot of time with former contractors to
be sure that we knew what we're doing
ahead of time and and if I were to do it
again I even make it simpler okay just
this distance distillation distillation
distillation or a reduction reduction
reduction of the process and in fact we
had seven bidders for the project and we
asked each of the bidders we will change
anything you want to change and none of
them wanted to change the system so so I
think I think we were we were on the
right path and so and and we always push
the limit and but it's an art of not
pushing the limit too far you know we go
into very high strength concrete but not
too high you know we obviously went to
very tall building but the you know we
were careful the things that that would
that we believed to be achievable and
here's and here's what here's what we
did to create this this thing to happen
I was telling you how Sears Tower is a
big beam this is a very very simple beam
okay and if you look at it and we call
it a buttress court there's our where is
it there we go there's our adjective and
now the core it is is the core around
around the elevators okay and we had a
huge debate about this the architects
were to propose a core then the
engineers were countered proposed and
back and forth and back and forth
because it's very important
architectural and very important
structurally and what the core does it
keeps the building from twisting and
there's been a lot of research about
buildings that all bunch of the
complaints there's
very high correlation between buildings
that twist a lot and people who complain
and and why is that okay how do you
perceive a building's moving well can
you see it moving if you if you're
moving frontwards and backwards and
there are no building near you or side
to side and there's no building near you
you can't tell if you're like the twin
towers where you had buildings next to
each other you can look out the window
and you can see that you're moving out
of phase but if you're building a
standing by itself you can't tell if
you're moving this way or this way but
if you're twisting the horizon is moving
on you okay you sit at your desk and you
look out the mullion and you look at the
horizon it's just like me rolling back
and forth so so we always want to have
something that that's very touristy
stuff and in a closed shape like this
bottle is very totally still you know
you get out to roll a trace that tube is
very touristy stuff but it's too slender
to go to great heights and this is part
of the paradigm how do you have a
structure that's very large but least
fans that are very normal okay
and and so what we did is we head to
buttress it okay so we stiffened it okay
and if the centre is like a tube the
wings are like I beams okay but instead
of an i-beam with the top flange and a
bite bottom floor then we have a Y beam
a Yale okay it's a Yale beam okay okay
so it's upside down yell sorry about
that anyway so you have here's here's a
web and a flange and a little mini
flanges in the demising walls another
one and imagine you had big wind loads
against these two legs well the last leg
buttresses for those of you who do like
residential construction it's quite
often if we're quite common to have we
call a bar building which will be like a
double load of corridor or something
it's long and rectangular and it's
always very very strong in the long
direction where there's no wind so who
needs it and it's very soft in the short
direction where there's the big wind
load because it's a big rectangle here
so this is kind of like taking three
residential buildings and having the
strength of one butters are strengthened
the weakness of the other two
and and and I think I think that's the
system can best be described by this
photo okay this is my system this is the
budget score okay yeah our gentleman
here has had some big win load so he has
his core and he's buttress and that's
that's that's the Burj Kalifa and and
and the system is so pure that you can
actually calculate by hand okay you know
you can actually calculate like moment
inertia radius gyration all the all
these kind of engineering terms that you
may or may not be familiar with and and
one of the things about we're talking
about how buildings are perceived okay
how do you okay we talked about can you
visually see a building moving can you
hear it move a lot of times you can okay
the serious terrace felt like a battle
ship creaking away in a windstorm you go
in the tower in a twenty days like wrong
and even I actually at least live in a
three flat in Chicago to did the same
thing you know it was really soft and
when the wind blows all the all the
partitions would get go from you know
rectangular to rhomboid you know and and
every time that does you know they they
squeak and they groan and they make a
lot of noise okay and in ordered and
even and this actually happens quite
often in small buildings we use it where
you have columns and beams I wonder if
the the British Museum maybe racks a
little bit okay you know I'd say you
know get beams and columns when the wind
blows the floor is distort and that that
infill panels gonna store it also okay
this building because it's almost all
walls there's virtually no shear racking
so that there's none of that partition
the reflections only come from
compression on one side and stretching
on the other and the building is very
very quiet but because of that and in
fact the movement on every floor is
about a millimeter or a millimeter and a
half at the head condition during a
windstorm so that's the system now one
of the one of the one of the things to
do in tall buildings is manage gravity
okay gravity's very reliable you don't
need an inspector okay so you use the
gravity to resist the wind loads okay so
so here's here's my
bring a coffee cup in here so I have
some water bottles okay okay so here's
one that's full and one that's empty and
the one that's empty it's much easier to
knock over than the one that's full
because the gravity got it right and
I've had a Dixie cup I think no Dixie
Cups structures are quite interesting
you know because you're they're
supported on the edge okay you know if
you look at any the only time you have a
flat bottom drinking cup is when you
have a relative it takes a pottery class
you know and they bring you on this
thing and it wobbles on the on the table
you can't throw it away because they
gave it to you but but you know it's
controlling gravity and this is what we
do we push the load out but you know we
take that gravity load and we push it
out and we push it out and and and make
it more and more stable okay and you
don't need an inspector in reinforced
concrete the the cheapest thing is
concrete the next most expensive thing
is formwork and the most expensive thing
is rebar so so instead of using rebar we
use gravity though there's a lot of
rebar - okay but here is the rebar at
the bottom of a half-mile tall building
if you were to walk up at that job site
for those of you in practice you saw
this rebar and you and someone said you
how tall do you think that building is
would you say ten stories twenty stories
because even on our storm that happens
once in 1,700 years we have no tension
okay because because we manage gravity
and we pushed it out and pushed it out
the then there's this incredible news
new material that's all around you
called concrete okay they really should
give it a new name okay well when I was
a student used to concrete joist I
always have to add a lot of water to it
to make it get in the forms I'm sure
here you got some bug holes occasionally
and and you do these slump test where
you have this one foot high cone you rot
it and you take off the cone and you
measure how much it slumps like three or
four inches and if you and if you
couldn't hear the forum you kept adding
water now we measured that a diameter of
the puddle
okay this tub is totally flowable and it
has almost no water in it just enough
water for the chemical
and so we're getting very very high
strength concrete and I actually think
that somebody should explore
architecture precast architecture mates
based on high-strength concrete that's
related to cast iron this stuff is about
as strong as cast iron used to be and
it's fireproof so except those sometimes
ten explode but you know fire but you
got to be careful of it but you know but
this is very very strong material and
and it's and it's almost unfair to give
it the same name as the stuff that's in
the sidewalk and so we took a great deal
of use of that the very top of the
building is structural steel I'm I'm on
the coach committee of the rights to
steel code for the US and so I tell all
my buddies look on the on the thing it's
actually a steel building with a very
tall foundation the now the very bottom
is we had this these are a hundred
ninety four five foot diameter she asked
about hundred fifty feet into the ground
we have a kind of a sandstone it's not
sand it's a calcium deposit rock we're
in and you might notice that I have
almost no piles under the middle of the
building you know what my piles are all
out the wing in fact the only reason
that pile there is because one of my
like guys who trained me kept on get on
my case that's the stand crystal pile
because I you know I just had to I had
to put a pile in the middle the building
just for Stan so that one's there but
but but that's the one that only takes
gravity load and that call that pile is
a thief I want all my gravity to help
resist the wind and a lot of times I'll
work on structures well I will try to
gut out the middle of the building and
put the structure to the outside and
open it up another one of my mantra is
the structure is obstruction okay you
know you can change the wall I can
change the McCallister's but you're
probably with that a few exceptions not
every to changing the structure so
whatever structure you put in there you
better be sure you're gonna live with
forever and and so you know pushing it
out we're making it open and and not
having these these these things in the
middle of the building that that robbed
the gravity from you and you can't use
it to spread out and resist the forces
now the dominant thing in tall buildings
is the wind even in California or high
seismic it's the
and what happens okay when when hits any
object like it be a lamppost or a
mountain the wind will go around and an
unstable irregular manner
first go to one side and then the other
and so you get these swirls and they'll
suck it to the one side and the swirl
will suck it to the other side and back
and forth and if this gets very
organized you can get huge huge forces
it's like a child on a swing okay you
know you know when you have young
children you cheat on swings say okay
see it see how the swing wants to move
you know you kicked your feet and you
get up and higher and higher and higher
and that's what happens and wind because
given the physical size of buildings and
the wind speeds that commonly curve
every building goes to resident vertex
shutting okay you will have a storm
which is going to excite your building
at its natural residence like this swing
and you get these huge huge forces so so
how do we deal with that well we did a
lot of wind tunnel testing okay and well
when our first a wind tunnel tests came
back the building did not work okay
one of my my references in life is The
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy okay if
you know you know the the the book
that's named in the title has written on
bold letters on the cover the other
Hitchhiker's Guide don't panic okay it
you know and that's that's one of the
things things will go bad in life this
thing went very bad and you know I
almost panicked but I you know you know
so I kind of sucked it in and started
working the problem okay what's
happening why is this building behaving
so badly and so we did it as we reshape
it and reshaped it and reshaped it the
building used to set back in a
counterclockwise manner we set it back
in a clockwise manner we turned the
whole building 120 degrees because the
prevailing winds and but first we had to
figure what the wind is okay we're gonna
design we're talking about 1,000 year
storms okay well they don't have any
records and we're talking about wind at
800 meters in there and not in the high
the the an anomaly at the at the airport
it's only 10 meters off the ground 33
feet and we're
extrapolate so they actually reduce a
weather really weather balloons in Abu
Dhabi twice a day and from that we were
able to get velocity profiles our deputy
either wooden consultant did for us and
then they were able to replicate storms
and say this is a velocity field at five
hundred meters were on ground based on
regional atmospheric model II and and
and from that we were able to to to try
to understand the wind profiles the
velocity profiles and we determined the
building has essentially six directions
and three nose this which act like cut
waters and three tails which cut the
wind which and those are the bad
directions when the wind came in between
two tails a vortex would peel off the
corner and then blow against the other
side and excite the building so what we
did is we shape the building and we call
this confusing the wind okay
remember the child that had the toothed
feet they were kicking in the same rate
every time you changed the width of the
floor plate or the shape of the floor
the vortex shedding rate will change so
that child now has 24 feet and they're
kicking at different rates so that so
the swing goes nowhere in a in our very
first model when told tests this is our
hundred year storm by the time we shaped
it twice the forces has gone from there
down to there just by changes the
geometry then we played with the
harmonics there's still a resident
component and and we actually got the
top of the building to move out of phase
with the bottom ability so sort to help
to help offset the their harmonics and
and so we grew from here we built this
we actually test that that one that was
what part of the subject fuse we ended
we went in the wind tunnel was but we
were planning to build this one but we
went in with that one to case the other
guys were in the wind tunnel measuring
remodel you know so and so we turn it
into a research project to see what we
could we could do we tuned it and what
we found is that here's our very first
study this is called force and this is
acceleration or move motion the building
we actually build had had one quarter
less force than the building within the
building it was three hundred meters
shorter because of this and the and the
accelerations
was a third less the pelling we took the
tallest one actually behaved better but
it was too late to change of course you
get to do all the cladding tests so that
those don't get sucked out we have one
pressure in the order of a hundred PSF
and in various places around the
building idea they wanted to occupy the
terraces and the first thing that came
to mind I used to have a friend who
lived in the Marina towers in Chicago
you know the corn cob okay and he had
this really ugly yellow chair that
looked like a hand okay on his balcony
and one day there was a storm he went
out and it was gone okay you know
hopefully floating down the Chicago
River and not hitting somebody and so
the first thing he went through my mind
was you better both the furniture down
but we did a whole series of studies to
how to make it more benign now that we
actually had a warning so sometimes you
don't go out and go out on your
terrorists and we did a series like ooh
you can see what we're playing with with
the with the the edge the edge
conditions and Farren's and we have
these baffles and it's like you know how
you go back to old Cary Grant movies you
know the winds blowing and their hair
and stuff like that but the modern
sports car like you've got a box or
something there's oh this screen behind
you so the wind doesn't come down on you
and that's what these baffles do the
wind comes over the parapet and then
stays up it doesn't and doesn't come
down and I've been I've been in the Burj
when it was really windy at ground level
and and I've been on the terraces in the
same day and it wasn't it was actually
less windy we holster is a treat but so
we had another scare okay if you if you
test a building a wind tunnel you can
change the geometry you can scale it
down we use buildings are one four
hundredth the scale you can scale the
structure but you cannot scale air air
at full scale is the same area blowing
through the window and so we had this
thing where and it's supposed to not be
sensitive to that we discovered that
that if he no matter how we blew the
wind faster than the wind tunnel it
would actually the forces were dropping
and then and we were worried that they
would actually come back up
so we had to do a special study just to
prove that this wasn't a problem so
here's just a small portion of the
building but it was a fairly large model
okay this one test cost us a hundred
thousand bucks just to prove that we
didn't have a problem with it with this
thing it's called a Reynolds number
integrationist system so but now
Jeannie's got to show it moment right
now on this thing and so that you can
buy this watch at moment it's the it's
the emceeing company anyway integration
of systems and this and this is my
values it's a ninety five dollars Swiss
watch is supposed to a fifteen hundred
ollars system it goes with my earlier
slides anyway but the integration of
systems I mean these buildings are Swiss
watches you have to locate everything
it's pretty high strength concrete's you
drilling later is probably not a good
idea
and so we located like every every pipe
and shaft and left a few extras for
things that come later and got them on
the drawing so a huge amount of thing
the whole debate about the elevator back
and forth back and forth for it took us
forever to fit up to all the others for
a long time we had the observation deck
lawyers hanging off the side of the
building but you know there's so
seriously we would you know you know as
of 2000 on the year 2010 we had five of
the ten telephones the world now we're
totally down to about three you know
because there's all these other
buildings coming the reason that we're
able to that of one office is not that
we're so good but it's because you have
architects and engineers talking
together at the same time and you can
you can resolve these issues early and
the and so there you know this is
critical to need to both architecture
and vertical transportation and
structure and so there was a huge amount
of back-and-forth proposals and
counterproposals on this uh lightning
okay the things a giant Faraday cage
because not only will get hit on the
topic you get hit on the side because
it's so tall and when I first when I
first topped out I would just get slides
like that all the time you know and now
it's like the lightning rod for Dubai I
was there once during a storm I saw it
got hit like once a minute BAM you know
these lightning bolts would just go just
hit the top of the spire
and I talk I talk to people it doesn't
seem to affect one of the interesting
things is the thermal dynamics of tall
buildings okay it's cooler in the
mountains right there's actually a I
climb it change as you go up
I remember going going up on the outside
the building and a man hoists on the
outside the building and like in July
like it's unbelievably hot and humid
there it's like 95% humidity 120 degrees
I'm aware Steve ever had by the time he
got to the 50th floor it was mostly
better by the time he got to 160 floors
it was pleasant it was still warm but
but but the humidity dropped the
temperature dropped and the dress dust
went away and so we use like we call it
sky sky source sustainability snorkeling
where we pull in that this this better
air for the mechanical systems issues of
scale everyone knows about Galileo and
and and Darcy Thompson but I'm going to
talk about you know animals small
animals look like this big animals look
like this but I'm going to talk about
Myron Goldsmith's version of scale
now Myron Goldsmith when he got his his
master's thesis with with Mies van der
Rohe he wrote this essay on scale at the
end and during his career he revised his
essays slightly about five times and and
it was it was in his final monograph
here with Rizzoli and when he talked
about is using the appropriate solution
and he and he would talk about structure
because that was the nature of his art
you know but what is the appropriate
solution what is the issues of scale for
the problem you're solving and unlike
nature we're where we have to where
nature has to evolve man could have
inspiration and create new solutions
that change the entire matrix that thing
things can happen and that's what the
Burj is the Sears Tower if you made it
bigger it would scale like I would by
the power of eight made it twice as tall
be eight times as big unbelievably huge
too big the Burj only scales by the
square make it twice too big it's got
four times the area it actually Frank
Lloyd Wright's mile high tower kind of
scales to this you know if I double the
height to this you're pretty close to it
Frank Lloyd Wright had in his mile high
tower and his structural systems
a little similar he had some bad ideas
but some good I guess you know and the
other thing is why are we doing this
building there's all these people were
announced the other these other world's
tallest building and one by one that got
cancelled and they were canceled because
I think people did not understand the
issues of scale that you cannot you know
like some of these buildings had 10
million square feet how do you write a
cheque for 10 million square feet how do
you sell and rent 10 million square feet
you know so it's the issues of scale you
know and these huge deep floor plates
buildings don't get built I think
they're because they don't have clear
ideas too complicated too difficult too
slow man time is your energy versus time
is money time is risk the longer you're
in the water they're more likely a
sharks gonna find you okay you know and
that shark could be a political upheaval
or financial or whatever you got to get
you eight buildings big and you always
have to have one idea of how you're
gonna build your buildings you know one
of my my boss is just say never propose
a solution with at least one idea how to
build it because if you have one idea
there's probably more than one way to
build it but if you don't have an idea
how to build it it might not be
buildable and I strongly urge that to
architects you know you know at least
come up with an idea then ask they've an
expert and you know hone your knowledge
the construction technology simple stuff
concrete here's the pile load test your
typical six thousand ton pile load test
this is not typical okay and we actually
never failed a pal so we don't know how
strong they are the groundwater is very
corrosive so we had to cathodic lis
protect it then what they wanted to
concrete in the middle of the summer so
we had to make these giant cubes of
concrete to see if we would boil the
water during the curing process we tried
different concrete mixes with we had
thermocouples in there to see if we were
going to cook the concrete and then they
cast it the cast of the mat and then
it's sat there for a while while the
client negotiated with a final contract
or the main contractor and then then
they wanted to pump concrete 2,000 feet
in the air I said it how do you figure
that out they said well we'll just run
pipes back and forth across the desert
floor until we with enough Bend
curves in it too you get the pressure
loss that's equivalent to pumping
vertically 2,000 feet and then they
tried different concrete mixes to see if
it was still concrete that came out and
the pump it's a good German pump called
up boots Meister you know this is a
great name for a pump so so here that
the contractor showed up in April 2005
and there it goes up it's a vertical
factory concrete you pump the concrete
the forms pick themselves up the only
thing yet to pick up of the hook is the
rebar cage and the wind blows through
that quite easily so you get a lot more
production up and up and up the cladding
contractor went bankrupt so we got to
see the structure for a long time
and some of the former was repeated a
hundred and sixty stories even though
the wings kept changing the center never
changed so they got a great speed they
finally got a grip on the Far East to
take it over you know that's the 70
story building right there you know the
top the top one to steel I tell you I
could have used some more editing on
this thing too fussy the they couldn't
they couldn't get a crane to the top to
build a spire so they had to build it
inside the building and hoist it out so
so here here's the spire inside the
building hanging from cables and this
thing at the base is like a lazy susan
you hoist it up to get the right floor
they turn at 60 degrees and set it down
and that and that's the the base of the
other spire there it is they got it up
there
somebody has to change the light bulb we
actually put blades on the top of the
spire to break to the fore to seize it
like a helical pattern on the spire
because we're worried about fatigue
lightning strikes and lightning strikes
this is the poltergeist one then
eventually you know you're cursed above
the clouds eventually they wash the
windows looked much nicer this is from
like a little over a year ago go quickly
here some of the views it catches its
slightly reflective so the caches of the
lights it's a I don't really have the
master plan here I apologize but the
place is totally
it's like a stage set and not like New
York City or Chicago where they explain
to you later why the tall buildings are
in Chicago not New York City the tallest
buildings you know there's more tall
buildings in New York but the tallest
ones are in Chicago the the but you know
it's a stage set they put this Lagoon
out front and and there's a giant mall
and all these restaurants of PIAT and
they have these huge but Bellagio la
gel-like fountain shows every night and
so it's it's a and a Dubai it's actually
a pedestrian place which is kind of
unusual there and the place is always
packed with people taking their
photographs in front of the building
there it is at night you know it catches
the morning and setting Suns you know
Adrienne is very good at that kind of
that part of it light then they have the
grand opening and I was in there very
smoke because I knew how tall it was all
right no no it's a big secret but I
didn't know they changed the name on me
okay because there was a birch two by
four for seven years and then also in
Kim's Burj Kalifa and of course they did
on Arabic so I didn't know what was
going on then they then they had the
fireworks and I've send their thinking
about that mannered hotel building that
burned up in Beijing I think this is
really not a good idea and more Hugh
Ferris showed up more and you know as
architects engineers we shouldn't kid
ourselves we make drawings these are the
guys who actually built up the
contractors you know and this guy KJ Kim
was like some Samsung constructions the
main guy and he actually built one of
the Petronas Towers for our neighbors
around here and he accidentally made his
tower 25 millimeters taller than the
other one so so he can say he actually
did the world's tallest building twice
of course you have to have owner
contractors so we were not licensed
there so hiders the engineer and
architect of record and so did we
okay going back to the original
questions is it an inspired dream or is
it will flex us okay we should always
think about these things and I don't
know I'm too close to it thank you
no hook no hook you did thank you for a
fantastic presentation of a fantastic
building I'm sure we have a few
questions in the audience about like how
did you do that what why Kyle life
inspect like and expectancy in the
building and quite frankly most tall
buildings its indefinite as long as you
keep the water out okay the the you know
water is the enemy but you know bridges
wear out because they will see their
design load many many times may have
what's called fatigue eventually the
steel will crack you know Ginny's father
was a bridge engineer and rural
structural engineer and I don't know he
knows all about this stuff anyway the
but buildings very rarely maybe never
see their design forces so they don't
really wear out the exception here is
the groundwater is so amazingly
corrosive that the foundation made some
point get eaten up so we ketotic lee
protect the foundations we have
sacrificial anodes we decided I think
for like a tune of your life and they
can then at that point they have to
replace the a nose but it does have to
be maintained and there's a monitoring
station the basement for the corrosion
but normally a building should last
forever if you wanted to other question
Jeanne gang wait we'll get you the mic
you turn that mic up how's that you it's
dead something wrong with this mic the
questions about the concrete constraints
that we use it actually wasn't that
ambitious okay
we used something that's called CAT
concrete which is a metric which is
basically about 9,000 psi C so in
Chicago Trump building we used 16,000
psi but we were afraid to push these
guys beyond their comfort level this is
like the upper edge of their car and we
use that for probably the bottom half
for the vertical elements the horizontal
almonds were normal were normal concrete
and then we went down to it from 90 to
2/3 of that so about 6,000 down to the
top but it was actually you know it's
interesting it's not that you know it's
not really that working that hard but
the concrete they delivered was actually
25% stronger than we ordered so because
they were they were scared and what's
interesting is the walls at the top are
about five hundred and fifty millimeters
wide and the walls at the bottom are 650
millimetres wide so barely four inches
wider you know from a little from you
know one foot 10 inches to 2 foot 2
inches is how much they grew and the
reason is because we kept adding walls
so so as the loads of cubed because the
loads under this building are quite
normal you know probably the point Tower
like if you tried you this narrow
footprint you know the structure the
loads get so concentrated that the
structure takes over the entire bottom
of the building where we're here we just
increased the bottom of the building and
and before we did this one I was
thinking about where could one do a
building like this and I was singing
that the Prophet the Trump controlled on
this in the 70s where he was a double
block you know that he did with New
World
over by over on the Westside oh he never
actually did them but yeah they did a
series of boys just put his name on ok
anyway but but those were actually
doubles marketed them but you know going
back to i answer the question i was kind
of teased you with the new york city
block is 200 feet right firm curb to
curb
right no from building line to building
a really mind-blowing okay the chicago
city blocks about 330 feet so therefore
you could have the bigger footprint in
that in that than that era so when
they're doing the steel buildings that's
why you know you know besides having
alleys in chicago the you know they
could they could get the bigger
footprint you know to go taller which is
one of the reasons the chicago doesn't
have near as many tall buildings as new
york would tend to have the taller
buildings big because of that john
Jacobson by here's a question have to
use this just a practical question
pumping concrete up 2700 feet how long
does it take to go from the bottom to
the top and secondly what happens to the
temperature or the concrete with the
friction between the tubes
yeah well the the the concrete they
actually the top was steel said they
only had pump in two thousand feet so
the it's the because last seven or fever
steel but they put ice in it they just
filled it with ice you know they they
they shave ice they put shaved ice into
the mix instead of water to cool it down
for when they they pump it as far as the
temperature increase I couldn't tell you
that but they did they they did those
studies just to see that thing so they
could and then they changed the
chemistry of the concrete as they would
hire to not because of the pumping
issues I don't know and I could tell you
how long it takes a person to go up
little over two minutes but the concrete
I'm not sure
the questions there are some questions
back there can you maybe talk a little
about how the very notion of building
tall relates to sustainability is it
sort of a good practice in that sense or
I guess if you're shaping eyes for
concrete you know like I guess in
construction how does that also play out
okay I'm not gonna talk about the birds
cuz it's kind of a unique thing let's
talk about Sears Tower okay you have for
4.4 million square feet on one city
block it's a couple blocks from looks
like kind of next to the hell it's very
close to Union Station it's not that far
from Northwestern station south streets
train stations are all right there it
had like you know very limited parking
okay the serious corporation moved out
okay and so so you go from this thing
where you have a hundred acres of
building and one city block so that they
move to Hoffman Estates and took over
they need a nice usual American saga to
go over farmland you know I I know if
you guys realize this but your car has
more space than you do
a typical parking spot is like 300
square feet accounting that the drive
aisle you know out front your office my
office is not 300 feet I'll tell you
that you know and so you know and
everybody has to drive to their
apartments and not 303 feet so you know
yeah so a part of it is maybe not tall
super tall but but tall density next Dix
transportation which usually implies
tall I think the New York City is
probably the better example where it's
the 40 story tall versus the you know
160 story tall around mass transit you
know is certainly I think the way the
field I believe I believe that you know
the you guys in New York have a much
smaller carbon footprint than Chicago
yes for reasons such as that through
very efficient in New York another
question there's a question in the very
back row wait a minute nobody if there
are people in the remote room that can't
oh okay sorry in your lecture you spoke
about staying calm and being fluid
during the design process to react to
changes were there any changes or issues
that came up during construction that
you had to kind of find in a unique
solution to that you're most proud of or
that that you think is interesting to
speak about this was actually the least
eventful construction jobs I've ever had
I've had worst problems on houses okay
I'm somebody ready Jeannie you know
we're the Samsung anticipated almost
everything okay and there were some
things that we had some rebar congestion
so we went from rebar to embedded steel
plates and some places but this all
worked out well ahead of construction
and so the you know it was like the you
know the better the highest complement
you can get you give to a contractor is
that that was pretty uneventful you know
and this was a very uneventful project
any more questions
what's the biggest impediment to
building like a two-kilometer building
or five well primarily but they're there
there are I could easily do a kilometer
building four is about the same amount
of its materials this one yeah above
above a kilometer or 1.1 kilometers I
have to I got some other systems I would
go to but Joe you can do it fairly but
you got to take care of the issues of
scale how do you get something that's
very tall and has a proper structural
size without creating unusable least
space and simple construction fast
construction and so you know my high
tower sure I was wondering what software
you use diffused digital project or what
you use to create for coordination you
know you know and we had a lot of curse
we have all kinds of special software
you know technology's changed a lot in
the last ten years right you know
nowadays we have like this group called
the black box and because you know right
now we'll have engineers who have got
all their software programs cooking and
will be fleeting data back and forth
between the architects and changing the
shape and going back and forth you know
and that's you know you know it's just
unbelievable we'll do be doing genetic
algorithms here to come up the new
shapes then testing it and look it looks
like the you know that's the stuff that
we we weren't doing ten years ago so
technologies really changed quick Gordon
wait a minute give the mic wait wait one
second not through concrete how would
you envision that this structure would
react if god forbid we had 9/11 we've
certainly think of such things but we're
not allowed to talk about it okay you
know it's just one of those those things
now it is interesting and I spend a lot
of time at Ground Zero you know they you
know they you know they the New York
structural engineers you know they were
getting fried remember is like no
Tuesday then like Thursday call it they
call desk
and you know the the twin towers did
very very well they took a whole goddamn
aircraft okay they sucked it in you know
and didn't collapse under that the fire
was it was something that I don't think
anyone really understood the issues
there you know so certainly concrete has
some advantage there you know but World
Trade Centers were very massive it's
kind of funny we actually did it we
actually did a momentum of calculation
and Cal we know how fast the plane was
coming and what the building ways when
its period is we were able to calculate
from conservation of momentum how far it
would move under the impact and it's
just how much it moved it was really
almost like a physics experiment kind of
a terrible one but yeah but you know the
fact that it took those two hits because
you know of all the I think almost every
structural engineer the desktop
buildings was like I was not sure it
would ever any belly would he would
supply survived the impact but the fires
we saw didn't look that bad and we've
seen much worse fires in buildings the
thing we weren't thinking about was that
all the fire proofing was gone from from
all the shredded airplane that went
through I'm ever you know the way the
aluminum wing cut the steel columns was
pretty amazing I was I remember I was at
NIST and there's this professor of IT
and he said well I grew up in Kansas and
we'd used to see these tornadoes we
would shoot straw through a through our
tree and Eternia is like 200 hours an
hour that those plays are going over 500
miles an hour okay
when they hit the tower so is this
pretty horrendous last question Jeanne
gang Oh dad and I will get to the fair
to ask how much it cost a square foot
that was pretty cheap it was a baybridge
cheap and and Dubois about 300 ollars of
square foot yeah jeanny including some
of the interiors
I always think because there's probably
a lot of architects here maybe you could
talk a little bit about the best
collaborations that you've had or what
would you what you judged to be you know
the best outcome how do you work with
architects well what I love is you know
like when we work together is getting
there before anything's down on paper at
som we had these tables that are 5 foot
square they're all of the office we call
it kindergarten tables and there's like
eight chairs you know nice chairs of
course you know em are chairs around the
side there's pinup space and you know
there's roll a trace okay and somebody
comes in well we got a new project
here's the site here's it look like
hundred square feet is and then and then
you start you start fighting for the
pencil okay I've never gone to one these
collaborations where I where we walked
away we're in the same place where
anybody came to the table okay and a lot
of times I'll find like I had this idea
okay and I'll describe an hour try to
sketch it and and then they will explain
my idea back to me but it wasn't my idea
it was something different you know it
got more filtered to their own ideas and
and you know and all sudden you end up
with something that's better than you
ever started and so this and also is we
do a lot of research and so we have a
lot of ideas that are in play okay
looking for the right opportunity yeah
you know Myron and father used to do
their research at IIT with with a
college of architecture students you
know the Hancock was originally
originally a master's thesis variety you
know and and the frame too was pretty
much developed as student projects and
the but but now what we're doing this in
the office and we have you know we have
a lot of things that we're studying and
we're looking for opportunities and and
so these things are in play and we we
pin up a lot of subliminal meshes
messages all over the office you know we
would come up something new we'll stick
it on the wall and said see if somebody
picks it up and then I also find it's
very good for kind of cross generational
collaboration you'll really senior
engineer working with a really junior
architect or they're really you know you
know senior architect working with that
you know a junior engineer
you know and and working together not
just principals talking to each other
but but the other thing and then that's
I think it's very good to have strong
technical architects as part of the
polite people who keep things you know
you know I got to say John you know Tom
fivers officer Ginny's office terrific
terrific technical architects you know
guys can really deliver the goods and
you've got to have them in the room but
when we started collaboration we will
have you know the architects the
technical architects the designer Textil
architects structural engineers a
sustainability guys will have black box
there they the computational guys you
know the mechanical electrical plumbing
guys they're all they're all there and
like okay what's the play you know
what's going on he's got a good idea and
and one of the problems with China right
now is there's just so many towers it's
almost like diluted and devalued the
whole skyscraper I'm most ready to give
it up you know me you know hey wait a
minute mom I want to finish mine but you
know that mean there's just so many
coming in and and everyone's going to be
different than the other and and and so
it's it's kind of that's a bit of a
problem that's why you're like houses
you know certain I wants to a house let
me know until you do a lot of them then
you want to do a tower any mosque
questions for our speaker thank you very
very much when credible evening